All my intentions that I want to calm down with you are not with you. I want to
calm down with love. I'm searching for the young person I'm destined for. The
words that
came out of nowhere are like excuses. The color of the wind in the sky is a mess. I'm
thinking about it so much that I can't even say it. It's so sick that I can't even touch it.  But
for some reason, I smiled as if I didn't know what was going on at night, and the morning was yours. Our eyes met, and we
began to move. Just
like spring, I won't say it will stay like this, but I don't want to save it yet, I
can't eat it yet, I
want to make a profit.  All my intentions are not with you.The
fate that I want to attach to love
[Music]
Young
Makuta
DET